الريال عنده مباراه قويه جدا امام الهلال
في نهائي كاس العالم للانديه هاي المباراه
راح تحط ريال مدريد امام ضغط كبير برايي
الشخصي وراح يكون الضغط عليه اكبر بمراحل
من الضغط على الهلال ريال مدريد مطالب
بتحقيق نتيجه ايجابيه وتحقيق اللقب امام
الهلال والا راح تكون كارثه فعلا قد تؤدي
لاقاله انشرتي لذلك الحديث عن انه هل
يستطيع الهلال هزيمه ريال مدريد اذا كسر
العامل النفسي نعم يستطيع الهلال قادر على
تحقيق اللقب الفرق بين الهلال والاهلي
المصري يكمن بجوده المحترفين جوده محترفين
الهلال على بشوي او بكثير ما بعرف من جوده
لاعبيه او جوده محترفين اهل المصري لذلك
اعتقد اذا الهلال نجح انه يركز يقدم
المباراه والاداء اللي بيقدمها بالحاله
الطبيعيه راح ينجح بانه يتغلب على ريال
مدريد بالنهائي ويحقق اللقب